well hello
everyone and welcome uh to the elaborate
event
uh the virtual one 2020.
um well my name is minya uh
and i'm a pg candidate
in sherwood lab at brigham and women's
hospital howard medical school
and today i'll be talking to you about
our latest work on
uh rendezvous like elucidating at your
investigator solid toxicity
using the crisper screen and transfer
because you cannot ask me directly
questions if you have any inquiries and
would like to know a little bit
more about this work you can find
a preprint on buyer archive of our lab
if we get started um the severe
this is a pre-existing drug developed
for ebola and marburg
and when death severe here is
a nucleoside analog and the way it acts
when it enters the cell uh
first transforms in its active
metabolite
and then it interferes with the action
of uh viral rna-dependent rna polymerase
so it competes with atp and it gets
integrated
into the viral rna and
that will cause the evasion of
proofreading by
viral exorbitance and it will cause a
decrease in viral irony production
so this drug is an antibiotic drug and
the reason why we got
interested in studying it it's because
it's hash
has shown some in vitro efficacy against
sars code 1 and sars code 2 but also has
shown some
imbue inficacy in mouse and macaque
models
so as i said it's a pre-existing drug
and it's been clinically approved
but so while clinical data suggests that
room destiny is generally safe for human
use
um destiny has shown some
silent toxicity so the causes and
mechanism of
toxicity are not fully known and we
wanted to study that a bit more
so this is important point to make
and it's unclear whether the amount that
could be given to a patient
it's limited by the toxicity of
rendezvous
itself so we wanted to know actually to
study
the metabolism of rendezvous within the
cells
and understand how the drug is being
metabolized
and this would help us understand which
patients might have
problems metabolizing it once it's been
administered to them
and then the second one is the toxicity
itself
and the point of this is that if we
could limit the toxicity caused by
reducing
or maybe we could give higher doses to
patients
um okay so to so we got
interested in studying the mechanism by
which when the severe affects whole
cells and induces cytotoxicity
and to do that we decided to do
rna-seq and genome-wide crispr screen
on the two liver and two intestinal
cell lines that we treated with so i
just want to point out here that
we know and we agree that like um
cell lines are not the best model to
study toxicity of a drug
and all they're doing this
same research with primary cells or with
organoids or
having an animal model would be much
better
still this high throughput screens that
we were performing require
the cells to grow very fast and we're
quite time limited so everything has
perks and styles so we decided to
go and work with this two liver and two
intestinal cell lines
and the reason why we chose them is that
because these organs are mostly affected
um by their individual toxicity
so rna-seq has been previously employed
to characterize drug my head
mechanisms and crispr screens have been
used to identify the genetic pathways
that
drive cancer drug resistance but
to our knowledge none of these two have
been used before
to study the toxicity of the rendezvous
so we have this four cell lines that we
treat when
we're in that severe and then we perform
rna-seq at eight and 24 hours
and as expected here you can see that
rna-seq gene expression clusters most
strongly by the cell line
and next one would be by the drug
exposure
so there is a clear evidence of
differential expression
and important to say is that there are
no strong
pro-prototypic gene expression
signatures so this validates their
dosing and duration in our experiments
are correct
and that everything that we are
observing is solely due to
a desperate treatment since
it induces this distinct host gene
expression response
so to investigate which genes and
pathways
change expression as a result of this
random treatment
we performed the gene set enrichment
analysis
this is a computational method that
helps you to determine whether
a defined set of genes uh shows a
statistically significant
difference between two biological states
in this case
our control and our rendezvous treatment
and we identified a set of highly
significant gene ontology pathways
affected by room designer in each of
these four
cell lines that we were working on and
so this
clear uh concordance in the pathways
regulated by urine the severe across
all the four cell lines that we were
using and then
they these pathways differ from the
pathways induced by a
control and hcq treatment
suggesting that each drug has a
signature impact on the cellular
physiology so what you see on the left
here
is a gca plot where basically each one
of the sticks
is showing a gene and it's ranking among
all of the other genes
so what you see is that for genes
involved in mitochondrial respiration
they're more off and they're more down
like down regulated than
up regulated and this allows us to do
gene by gene analysis whose results you
can see here on the right
so the main drug specific gene
expression response of
is this significant decrease in the
mitochondrial respiratory gene
expression
and you can see on the right here that
ramdas severe strongly represses
nuclear genes that encode for
mitochondrial raspberry complex 1 3
4 and 5 as well as other genes that
encode
mitochondrial and localized proteins
but it does not significantly impact the
expression of genes
encoded by the mitochondrial genome
itself
so now we know that a
rendezvous acts on gene expression like
this we wanted to we know what happens
on the gene expression level
but we wanted to see and determine the
functional impact
from the severe um on this mitochondrial
gene repression so we performed
uh flowcytometric measurements uh two
kinds of them
uh atp red and matara's 580.
so on the left you can see the results
of atp red and atp red
is just a dye a red fluorescent dye
and it's approved for atp so once
it's administrated to the cells
it enters the mitochondria of living
cells and
it targets the atp and this way we can
measure the atp
levels so you can see on the left here
that
the cell lines that are treated with
drum death severe
significantly decrease the production of
the atp
and on the right you have the results of
mitoras 480
so miter ross is just this super oxide
sensitive dye
um and it's localizing in mitochondria
as well
once in its administrative to the cells
um
it will this dye will be oxidated by
superoxide and it's specific to
superoxide from mitochondria i will not
be
reactive to the other um reactive oxygen
species in the cells so you can also see
that there is a decrease in the
mitochondrial respiration once the cells
are treated with their own desire
um
so given that remdessever decreases the
expression
of the genes involved in microcontroller
respiration
and atp reduction we ask whether
the drugs that affect mitochondrial uh
oxidative phosphorylation can impact
the reductive or cytotoxicity so we set
a set of five drugs that were previously
known to impact mitochondrial function
and found that
when death severe toxicity in cells
is quite mitigated by
this drug called cyrosincopine
which is a lactate transporter inhibitor
that down regulates the mitochondrial
reactivity
so once we treat the cells with cyrus
single pine and with rendezvir
we have the this like mitigation of the
rendezvous cytotoxicity
then the next drug that we used uh is
called um
urzodez oxycolic acid and this drug has
been shown to improve the mitochondrial
function
when we treat the um cells with
uh oozodes oxycolic acid acid
and um when death severe as well
we see that around the decision toxicity
in cells is quite
um extraordinary
and then we have these three
next three drugs that are fact affecting
mitochondrial activity but once we
administrate the render severe and these
drugs
there is no significant impact on the
toxicity or from death severe
which is a bit um a bit
dampens our enthusiasm about our
findings about this
just because one of these drugs um
metformin
uh is known to down regulate as the
mitochondrial activity
as well as cyrosinopene does so you have
these two drugs that should have
the same mechanism of action but they do
not produce
the same results so this might indicate
that there is
a bit of nuance in the way that this
toxicity is being shown
um so now we saw how does gene
expression change after industry
treatment we wanted to
directly identify which genes are
involved in rhetoric
severe metabolism and cytotoxicity
so we performed a drug toxicity crispr
screen
and the way we do this we have genome y
targeting crispr
library um which is just a library of
guide rnas they're targeting
over 20 000 genes and each one of these
genes are covered by four guides
um and then we treat the cells uh with
this library we make sure that we select
for the cells that have library
integrated within them
and then treat the cells um with
ramdesevere
and our control and wait to see what
happens
so after a while we will have
some guide rnas that will be depleted
from population
or enriched in our population and
genes whose knockouts will
increase the drug toxicity uh those
uh guides rna will be depleted in our
population
and then those genes that knock out
mitigates the
drug toxicity will be enriched in this
rendezvous
treated samples so
these are our results and um
we run this medjay pipeline to
see what happens and which guide rna got
enriched or depleted by running this
pipeline
we will have this kind of graph
where you can see on the right and on
the left
on the left would be jeans whose
knockout will
increase the drug toxicity and those
guide rnas will be depleted for our
population
and we observe this significant
depletion of kyrones that are targeting
cell essential genes
after two weeks of drug
or dmso treatment which is kind of nice
because it just confirms that
our crispr system is quite robust and
it's working itself cells
and on this um left side we have also a
depletion
of cad rnas that are targeting genes
involved in pure bison
so this kind of makes sense because as
we
said at the beginning that rimdesver is
a nucleoside analog
and once it enters the cells it will
compete with atp
for the integration in the viral rna so
if we don't have these genes that are
involved in pure biosynthesis um
then there will be no competition
with atp and the cells
will actually have this
huge amount of room deserve and that
will cause
the increase in drug toxicity
um and then on the right side here we
have
guide rnase um there are targeting genes
that will help mitigate the drug
toxicity
these guidelines will be enriched and
these are
one of our top hits that we will cover
now one by one
so we perform this individual validation
of guides they're targeting the six
genes whose loss significantly mitigated
run desperate toxicity in their our pool
screen
and all these hits are confirming
significant increase
in cc 50. so if we go for the first one
the first was the guide rna that was
targeting
ct and cdsa is
gene coding for catapsin
and catapin a is a first step in the
processing
of ramdas severe so
it is an estuaries known to be involved
in the
interstellar activation of these
nucleoside
projects and this provides
a genetic confirmation that ctsa is a
primary enzyme
in the initial intercellular and the
severe activation step
so once we have a knockout cell line of
this gene
we are we were able to see this
increase in cc50 of the drug
um the next one would be keep one
which is involved in mitochondrial
activity
and it also refers us back to our
rna-seq data
so guidance they're targeting keep one
show
around 3.2 volt increase in cc50
and these knockouts should stabilize and
activate the
nrf2 transcription fact this factor
when it's activated is increasing a set
of
antioxidant stress response and it's
increasing the mitochondrial function
and purine biases synthesis and this
suggests that
rnf2 activation may protect
against from desperate toxicity it kind
of makes sense because if
our nrf to activation
leads to increase in pure synthetic
appearance
synthesis that will mean more atp
to compete with desire and mitigate the
toxicity of from the severe cell
then we have these two next gyronase
that are targeting
um two mitochondria localized metabolic
genes
and they're the first one is ak2
it's um adenylate
kinase and then the second one is this
bi-directional
nucleoside transporter slc2
and both of these guy rnas are highly
enriched
in our full screen and we when we do
this
individual validation of these two
guidelines
we see the significant increase
in cc15 so
um we have an slc2 and ak2
notably this ak2 has been shown to be
involved
in the activation of the anterior violet
drugs
and slc-2 knockdown has been shown to
reduce the mitochondrial
transport of some other nucleotide
analog drugs so when we treat the
knockouts of ak2
and when we cheat the knockouts of two
with room december
we find that cc50s dramatically increase
and this suggests that these genes are
common cellular mediators
of rhindest mirror toxicity
so we had this quite easy sheen
to start with um but
then through our crisper screen
we were able to fill out a lot of these
blank spots
and things we didn't know before and
those are the steps in the metabolism
and toxicity or from the severe so from
this relatively simple picture we were
now coming to this a bit more complex
with much more explanation
so these results that we had got us
really excited because our genome white
screen is giving us these
two mitochondrial genes that validate
that we are sort of on the right track
right and now we have these two
mitochondria genes that we know that are
involved in toxicity
but could it be that they're also
involved in metabolizing the drug
so we wanted to know whether
these two ak2 and slc-2
are involved in the only intoxicity of
the rheum deserver
or are they involved in metabolizing the
drug itself
and the way to answer this question we
came up
is that we wanted to do a viral china
a challenge assay and to do that we had
help of our collaborators so
to address whether this loss of ak2 or
slc-2 impacts the potential from that
severed as an
antiviral drug we tested rendestive
response
in this source co2 virus challenge
so we have control cells and we have
knockout cells
and they're treated with a range or from
decibel concentrations
and then they're affected with the viral
supernatant
and then after 48 hours we
fixate the cells and do fish analysis
um trying to detect this rna from
the sars cove two and we found
that stars cov2 ic50 forum desever
is increased only slightly by slc-2
knockout as compared to control rna
but ak2 knockout induces of this robust
increase in the render severe ic15
so it comes down to this
that for ak2 we observe this
22-fold change in both cytotoxicity
but as well is in antiviral potency
so basically the implication is that
those are connected and the reason why
rendezvous is less toxic
in ak2 knockout is just the fact that
there is just
less rim deciber there
and now we show something that has not
been shown before that ak2 is a
rendessory kinase
that is required to activate from
desiree as a project
so basically if you do not have a
functional ak2
kinase you will not have the active
urban december form in the cell
but for slc two the main difference
is between this eightfold change in cc50
and uh 1.9 volt change in the bottom
left uh viral challenge essay
so you can see here
in the bottom left that this is an
argument that this
is a target gene that might be an
interesting
um drug candidate because it allows us
to
preserve the potential from the severe
while at the same time
it lowers the cytotoxicity of the
rhombus severe
so this in parallel would allow us
for potential higher dose
administration which is
one of the problems when using the
rendezvous
so we have this now full picture of how
rinda's severe
acts in the cells and our results
suggest that targeting
this bi-directional mitochondrial
nucleus
transporter slc2 robustly reduces swim
desired
cytotoxicity and we show
through our genome-based approach that
when the severe primary effect on the
cell is
reduction of mitochondrial respiratory
gene expression
of the genes transcribed from nuclear
genome
we saw that there is reduction in
mitochondrial
we saw that there is also reduction in
atp
production in mitochondria and
most interestingly interestingly we
found that
the ak2 kinase is a kinase very
important
for the rim the severe metabolism
and we show that this slc-2
is a potential target to reduce toxicity
of nucleus eye drugs such as room
deservier
so one of the actual ways that we think
this is happening is because uh slc-2
here
you can see on the lower left picture
is this transporter localized on the
outer but also in the
inner membrane and if we have a knockout
of this
it might prevent the
rendezvous being transported into the
matrix
and once when the severe is in the
matrix of mitochondria it's where
it's um action on the like
toxic toxic action is being happening
but
um if remdessever and its active form
is found in the cytoplasm that that is
where
the rendezvous will act as an antiviral
drug
so this kind of pictures
paints a really clear picture of what is
happening within the cells and we were
able to do this
by just doing this crispr screen and
rna-seq
and i would just like to take a moment
to thank everyone in the lab
for working really hard on this
especially
uh ersin and minson who were working
during
our lockdown when we were quite limited
with the people that we
had in the lab so they did majority of
the work
uh i would also like to thank our
collaborators
uh philippe cole uh professor
david arthur uh and our collaborators
who helped us with the the spiral
challenge isa
from professors at david's lab
and i want to thank everyone for
listening to my talk
okay awesome job well we're all set
pretty much from here i will just do
some quick editing on the front and
back ends since there was no
interruptions during
and then we'll have your presentation
ready for the event next week
okay great thanks a lot of course any
questions for me before we wrap
up um no
okay perfect well if anything comes up
feel free to reach out but if not
the event goes live next week on
wednesday if you want to attend live if
not it'll be available on demand for six
months after another
okay okay thank you alrighty have a
great weekend
thank you for your time thank you bye